the One Piece manga has just added a
shocking twist to Kuma's backstory which
has left me desperately rereading every
single panel of Kuma Bonnie and Luffy's
interactions to see if maybe just maybe
there is a real chance that Luffy and
Bonnie are actually related and all of
this comes because at the end of this
chapter Kuma mysteriously arrives at
fusha Village which in case you don't
remember is of course where Luffy was
born and raised and started his
Adventure from so what is Kuma doing
here well we aren't quite shown yet but
since the backstory is not over yet I
imagine that we will be finding out very
soon however of course that isn't going
to stop us from speculating what this
all could mean and how it completely
changes what we thought we knew about
Kuma and Luffy and so to kick things off
let's go through the possibilities for
as to why Kuma might have actually come
to fusa village now do keep in mind that
this is all after Kuma has been turned
into a cyborg already and has had his
memories to some degree altered as well
however we do in fact know that he
didn't have all his memories erased
completely until the time skip so at
this point in the story he very likely
still very much remembers most of who he
actually is and so maybe the most
obvious reason that Kuma would come to
Luffy's Village is of course because of
Monkey D Dragon who is the Revolutionary
Army's commander-in-chief and Kuma's
friend who incidentally was also most
likely Born and Raised on this island
and so it is entirely possible that Kuma
was coming to meet dragon and talk to
him about his plans now that he was a
cyborg now of course you might be saying
that there is no way that Kuma would do
this since he is now partially already a
government slave but do remember that
Warlords are basically free to do
whatever they want unless they are given
a direct order by the world government
which as we've seen doesn't happen all
that often now on top of that Kuma has
shown us many many times in the pre- EK
era that he would follow his own will
instead of just blindly following the
world government's commands in fact
during the Sabah OD AR he even tells Ry
that he is still an officer in the
Revolutionary Army so all of that is to
say that it's completely possible that
Kuma is still acting as a revolutionary
at this earlier point which makes it
very much possible that he would just go
and meet with dragon here but why would
he do that well the most logical reason
is that Dragon asked Kuma to watch over
Luffy which just makes a whole lot of
sense because of Kuma's actions later on
during SL bark and sabba ODI for example
if you need a reminder after the straw
hats defeated the warlord geodia here
Kuma was actually tasked with wiping out
everyone on the entire Island by the
government including Luffy and the straw
hats and yeah I do know that I'm trying
to convince you that Kuma is an ally
here but if you remember for a few
chapters it certainly looked a lot like
Kuma was just going to straight up kill
all of them pretty easily now of course
in this scene here it's kind of
debatable how much free will he actually
has left here and how much of that was
his Forest government program com but
eventually he actually does let the
stats Escape after zoro's display of
loyalty but then in chapter 485 as Kuma
was just about to leave the island he
then revealed that he already knew that
Luffy was in fact dragon's son in other
words very clearly he must have already
learned about Luffy and dragon's
relationship at some point in the recent
past and while you might think that it
would be pretty simple to connect Luffy
to his father because of their shared
family name not many characters in the
story were actually able to do that in
fact even some of dragon's most trusted
allies in the Revolutionary such as Ivan
kof here didn't even know that Dragon
even had a son and so very clearly this
wasn't common knowledge which means that
Kuma must have learned it in some sort
of very unique situation which of course
makes Kuma's surprise visit to the Goa
Kingdom at the end of this chapter the
perfect opportunity for Dragon to reveal
that he has a son and ask Kuma to watch
over him as best as he can from within
in the world governments which is just
amazing if that was somehow planned
right from the very start of the story
and honestly I think that really just
goes to show that this entire Arc so far
has had some of the best character
writing in all of One Piece ever and as
you know that really says something may
I remind you that we just had a giant
blue alcoholic dragon as the last big
villain who I still think by the way was
super underrated as a character building
his own Empire in wano and if you ever
felt like you also wanted to have your
very own personal dragon Empire worry
not because today's sponsor allows you
to do just that in Dragon City you can
collect hatch and evolve not just one
Mis kaido or MOS but over 1,000 unique
and Powerful dragons and instead of just
living inside a big skull or inside an
egg you can build and customize your
very own Dream City with its own magical
habitants and buildings just like Luffy
you can embark on an adventure filled
with tough enemies ancient legends and
mythical creatures fighting other Dragon
Masters in Epic PVP battles to prove
your strength and use your very own
dragon powerful skills to master
challenging quests and events so make
sure to get Dragon City by clicking the
link in the description or just scanning
the QR code here and get a special
bundle with 15,000 food 30,000 gold and
the very rare spaceship Dragon to get
you started and speaking of spaceships
and advanced technological beings that
brings us right back to this chapter
because in fact some parts of the story
actually kind of go against the idea
that Dragon actually asked Kuma to watch
overloop for example Kuma's visit to
fusha Village must have happened
sometime around 3 or so years before the
current storyline very shortly before
Luffy left for his adventure and this
would have been just after Kuma had
become a warlord now at this point Luffy
was still at fusa Village but Ace had
already left to become a pirate and had
already defeated a warlord himself and
so that just makes me wonder how would
Dragon be able to keep tabs on Luffy but
then not know that he was actually going
to become a pirate since it does seemed
like this was very much new information
to him back in chapter 100 which by the
way is now 1,000 chapters ago and I mean
becoming a pirate was Luffy's dream all
along and I'm pretty sure that everyone
everyone in fusha Village very much knew
that he wanted to be a pirate this whole
time that Luffy was growing up so sure
you could say that dragon is not the
greatest father and even if he was
watching Luffy he might not have figured
out what he wanted to be but for now
let's just assume that that isn't
actually the case and the Dragon did not
in fact invite Kuma to fusha Village
after all so then you could ask what
other possible reason could Kuma have
for coming to this Kingdom well there
are actually a few other really really
fascinating reasons that I can think of
and one of them is absolutely going to
blow your mind with its possibilities
but to begin with it is possible that
Kuma just went there for some unknown
reason that we will find out in the next
chapter or so it could have just been
completely random though it doesn't
really seem to have been ordered by the
world government itself and it's also
possible that Kuma went to fusha Village
because this was the island that he and
jinny were supposed to meet up on before
jinny was actually captured we actually
learned about this back in chapter 1097
so maybe just maybe Kuma went there for
nostalgic reasons or just to remember
something about his past love but
another possibility and oh boy we're
going to have fun with this one this one
also involves jinny but gets way more
interesting so to start with let's make
sure that we all understand a few key
details here first off jinny was the
Revolutionary Army's Eastern forces
Commander so it is entirely possible
that jimie already had visited fusa
Village or the larger islands which is
called Dawn Island sometime during her
time with the Revolutionary Army and in
case you forgot jinny was very much part
of the revolutionaries from about 22
years ago until she was captured about
14 years ago which does mean that she
was probably in in the East blue for
quite some time now the point that I'm
trying to get to here takes us way back
to some of the initial speculation
surrounding jinny when she was first
introduced back in chapter 1095 and that
of course is that jinny might actually
be Luffy's Mother after all I mean she
was most likely in the East blue around
the time that Luffy was born which was
19 years ago she does have very close
ties with dragon as well as all of the
other reasons that she might be Luffy's
mother that we have already discussed in
previous chapters such as the
similarities with eating lots of food
and the similar names and at that time
we had actually thought that she might
be Luffy or Bonnie's mom but what if she
was both Luffy's and Bonnie's Mother
after all now you might already be
typing away in the comments right now
that there is no way that she would
betray her love for Kuma like that I'm
just saying it's possible the math kind
of works out and even if that's not the
case I still wonder if she could have
met Luffy at one point and she was in
inspired by his personality just like
Shanks was however keep in mind that at
this point Luffy wouldn't have had
either his straw hat or his devil fruit
when jinny was around here because he
didn't get either of those things until
at least one year after jinny was
captured timeline is a little bit
confusing but still Luffy is pretty hard
to forget as a kid so even if she isn't
his literal mother maybe jinny figured
out that he was dragon's son and
mentioned it to Kuma which then led to
Kuma here as we see in this flashback
actually now that I'm thinking about it
I kind of wonder if there is one other
possibility for why Kuma actually came
to Luffy's home Island because remember
that Kuma is part of the buccaneer race
who is very much known for believing in
the god NAA we also do know that NAA is
commonly refer to as the sun god and
Kuma's father believed that NAA would
bring freedom back to the world and well
one thing that we know for a fact is
that all throughout one piece is that
the dawn or the Rising Sun is very much
often used as a symbol of freedom in the
story so what if part of Nika's lore
that Kuma knows about also relates to
Luffy's home which once again is called
Dawn Island as being part of some
special prophecy or something like that
this would very much also explain why he
went against the government on sabba ODI
and why he made Vega Punk make it his
mission to protect the Thousand Sunny
for two years because he had some idea
that Luffy would become NAA or let's
throw all of this out of the window a
completely different Poss ility here is
that Kuma came here with a very
different purpose altogether because one
of the special things of course about
Kuma's devil fruit is that it can also
do some truly overpowered and incredible
things like pushing out memories for
example so what if he actually came to
do something similar to Luffy at this
point I mean we all do know that Luffy
didn't even know who his father was
until his grandfather told him back in
chapter 432 and we all just assumed that
Luffy was just being an idiot like usual
but what if instead Kuma actually
somehow pushed out Luffy's memories of
his parents for some other unknown
reason now admittedly it does sound a
little bit sketchy for Kuma to do
something like that plus that means that
Luffy might have known about his parents
during most of his childhood but still I
still think the idea of Kuma taking
something away from Luffy by pushing it
out of him could come back around in the
future especially if Kuma had a hint
that Luffy might actually be NAA which
does sound crazy I know but I'm just
throwing it out there but if there's one
thing that has been most surprising
about Kuma's flashback so far is how he
literally has connections to so many
characters and places all around the
world and I mean just last chapter we
saw how he visited all the places he
sent a straw hats to during the time
skip so at this point I want to make one
more Connection in regards to Bonnie
listen to this one thing I just haven't
been able to figure out this entire
flashback so far is how this back story
actually would tie into Bonnie's future
because one thing that flashbacks and
one piece always do is clarify a
character's motivations and dreams we
saw it with Chopper's inspiration to
become a doctor Robin's dedication to
becoming a scholar and even lost desire
for vengeance against doflamingo in fact
if we take it even further extensive
flashbacks like this are usually safe
for future straw hats or characters that
will be important allies for the straw
hats in the future like take viv's
flashback for example or the wano
flashback which showed Momo's birth and
upbringing however both of these
characters are leaders of important
countries who will no doubt come to
Luffy's Aid at some point in the future
but Bonnie here certainly isn't the
leader of a super strong country unless
she is secretly the new queen of sorbet
Kingdom I guess but assuming that sorbet
isn't some super military power that
leaves the main reason for her being
involved in a flashback like this being
that she is now a potential Straw Hat
candidate and in fact the more you look
into it the more she starts fitting a
lot of the criteria that that are
required for characters to join the crew
first off she obviously has a very
tragic backstory next if she wants to
fulfill Kuma's dreams of helping NAA
bring freedom to the world inherited
will that is a clear dream that she can
fulfill while traveling with Luffy as
for her role on the crew well take the
fact that she's only 12 years old right
now then she could certainly fill the
role of cabin girl or Apprentice much
like Shanks or buggy were on Rogers crew
although that might be a little bit of a
stretch considering that despite her age
she has already been a pretty famous
captain on her own when she aged herself
up however funnily enough this idea of
Bonnie making herself seem older than
she already is also relates to the next
part of why she could be such a perfect
Straw Hat candidate because one other
thing that every potential Straw Hat
must have is that they need Luffy to
free them somehow for Nami for example
it was literally freeing her from arlong
for Robin it was giving her the
confidence to know that she deserved to
live and freeing her from enna's Lobby
for Sanji it was helping him understand
and that it was okay for him to follow
his dreams and well for Bonnie she also
has something that she needs to learn
and be freed from which is that she
doesn't have to pretend to be an adult
when she still is just a kid I mean for
as long as we've known her she has been
pushing herself to be an adult with her
devil fruit Powers she's been doing this
pretty much all the time as she fights
to find Kuma and free him from the world
government yet all this time she has
refused to believe that Kuma sacrificed
himself for her and it's honestly super
sad and tragic that she refuses to
believe that Kuma would in fact choose
to become a Mindless slave as we see
during this conversation with Aku during
the time skip here and so the way that
Luffy can actually save her is to gain
closure from the fact that Kuma
sacrificed himself so that she can have
a normal life so that she doesn't need
to pretend to be an adult and so that
she can just be herself it's kind of
similar to Chopper really who believed
himself to be a monster until the crew
accepted him as who he was so again
there is a lot of potential here for
Bonnie to actually join the crew after
this Arc then again it is possible that
she might not in fact Bonnie already
seems to have made some piece with her
father's memories as we saw back in
chapter 1090 and in this scene right
here Luffy points out that Bonnie is
acting much happier than before and she
says that she feels much better than the
day before when she first saw her
father's memory so maybe she is already
starting to accept what Kuma did for her
but now even though we spend so much
time talking about the plot twist at the
end let's touch a little bit on the
other parts of the chapter here because
much like we expected Saturn interfered
with mega Punk's planted operation and
added the condition that Kuma must have
his memories erased by the end of the
procedure which I mean I every Arc Oda
makes us hate a new character even more
than he did in the last one and Saturn
is definitely living up to the newest
biggest scumbag in the entire story I
mean strangely enough though Kuma's full
cyborg transformation will take two full
years to complete so I guess they're
doing it in increment and stages but by
the way Kuma very happily accepts this
Arrangement if it means that Bonnie will
be cured also we learned that Bonnie's
treatments to cure her disease will take
6 months plus another year of staying
out of the sun to 100% recover which is
how we get this awesome family bonding
time during this chapter of Kuma bunny
Vega Punk and sentomaru and even kizaru
enjoying themselves on EIT Island in
between surgeries which again just as a
reminder to us means that kizaru really
was friends with all of these people so
he might very well still have a change
of heart and decide to help his former
friends which I would love to see and
once this time is actually over though
Bonnie is then taken back to the sbet
kingdom where she lives inside the
church under the watch of a medical team
who are really Cipher pole agents who
are there to keep track of her and all
of that is so that Kuma is forced to
follow through with the procedures to
have his memories erased as well and
Bonnie will only be fully free once Kuma
is fully a govern government slave which
might actually finally explain this
conversation with ainu back in chapter
595 where the former Admiral was legit
worried that Bonnie had escaped because
to me that just means that Bonnie ran
away from cyop pole before Kuma's
memories were fully erased meaning that
Kuma could have left the world
government without actually fully
following through with the procedure and
so I really wonder if Bonnie's condition
might show up again since she might not
have completed the full year of recovery
here and her leaving her quarantine
early actually also brings up the
question of why Kuma didn't leave the
government once she had escaped did he
just not know that Bonnie had escaped or
was he worried that the government would
just capture her again if he rebelled or
did he have another reason for actually
staying with the government like maybe
he had some other mission that he wanted
to fulfill for the revolutionaries or he
actually was looking out for Luffy all
along in fact it is almost certain that
Luffy and the crew would have been wiped
out at Saba ODI if it hadn't been for
Kuma plus he defended their ship for 2
years so all of that is just more
evidence that he was doing all that he
could to make sure that Luffy had every
chance possible to reach his full
potential and we're not sure at this
point but one thing is certain and that
is that this backstory just continues to
get more and more tragic I mean come on
I Kuma writing a letter to the daughter
that he will never meet again Kuma with
the heartbreaking Last Words thank you
for being born bunny laughing even
because she thinks that they can finally
go back to being a family I mean please
I know some people are more than ready
to actually get to the end of this
backstory and get back to the action on
ekad island but this is Peak Oda story
writing in its perfect shape or form and
I really can't get enough of it honestly
I might even rank this backstory right
up there in my top three Back stories in
the entire story but if you want to
decide for yourself by comparing it to
every other backstory in all of One
Piece you can watch that video right
there also once again thank you to
Dragon City for sponsoring this video
don't forget to check out the game with
the link in the description Shanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one